all right guys comic-con is on the way
we're here right now because we're gonna
watch the Wonder Woman comic-con trailer
I'm really looking forward to this I'm
excited that patty Jenkins is directing
this movie gal gadot is someone who I
was really impressed with with bbs one
of the few things I really liked about
that movie and she's very beautiful
easy to look at I could tell she does a
lot of core exercises very impressed
with your fitness routine gal anyway
yeah this is like a really anticipated
is a big [ __ ] trailer whose pod Steve
you man she's beautiful yeah oh wow
yeah
I just watched the DC Animated Wonder
Woman being my greatest love
Wow shot really well
be careful Diana
Hey wrecker oh go [ __ ] some [ __ ] up
no IV never met a man before her what
about your father I had no father
nope it was about to life places hell
yeah
well that's me
whoa god damn
change the war man
I got you
[ __ ] yeah man [ __ ] Wonder Woman
oh [ __ ]
it's as a candy I'm Steve hoppers
secretary what is the secretary I go
where he tells me to go when we do what
he tells me to do or where I'm from
that's called slavery
I'd really like her that's the please up
you're eating like a good slave Joe Kopp
I didn't mean that
that was me that slavery is not funny I
don't know any slavery going on today
heard like tripe okay you know what try
not to offend this time try not to
offend sorry wow there's so much in that
trailer I really did enjoy I love that
this is a period piece you know I was
kind of thinking of the Captain America
the First Avenger I know that's marble
phone whatever I think this film is shot
beautifully a visual aspect the the
aesthetic appeal of it is very great the
production design is wonderful it really
does look like a period piece during
this war with Wonder Woman in the middle
of it that's what I really like because
I'm like this looks like a legit period
piece that happens to have Wonder Woman
in it yeah this film looks like it's
gonna be really epic I love how it's not
like crazy handheld patty Jenkins I
don't really know her to do action films
but I really feel like she's got the
action down in this one man it looks
really [ __ ] cool I really feel like
for gal gadot gatot whatever for uh
Diana I really feel a sense of
vulnerability a sense of loss with some
hope you know like there's there's a
really strong darkness to her because
I've always sort of perceived Wonder
Woman as I am Wonder Woman I am an
Amazon goddess or whatever they're
called like there's something about her
Wonder Woman portrayal that seems very
human and very emotional something that
seems kind of like rather missing inside
of her heart I think Chris Pine is Steve
Trevor is an excellent choice I just saw
all three Star Trek films that he was in
and I watched Jack Ryan I think he
reminds a pretty fun actor it's cool to
see him taking on this supporting role
who's an important person and Wonder
Woman's life knowing the character of
Steve Trevor for what I've seen from the
animated film I think Chris prime Chris
Brian I think Chris Pine is perfect for
this means something tells me that
Trevor will die in the end of this movie
or less he's gonna you know live to be
very old kind of like a Peggy Carter
thing but then I don't think they want
to copy more
that much what I like too is you know
especially after coming off of like BBS
I feel like the tone of this has a lot
more going for it I mean there seems to
be a good balance of humour drama action
like I feel like there was a lot of
different colors in life to this trailer
that I was expecting and I thought I was
just going to get a really dark suit
should I really feel like with Chris
Pine and his interaction with one or
woman that really makes a difference in
terms of tone I want to see you the main
villain is I'm intrigued I'm you know no
matter what even if this film you it's
like zero percent on Rotten Tomatoes I'm
still going to check it out anyway guys
more comic-con trailers coming at you to
talk about if you're new subscribe to
day become rejected why not do it follow
me on Facebook Instagram Twitter we got
more videos to watch tuning out now